donc sauf avec latine juste là oui c'est
ma fille ses notes future maison à
maison familiale de voir la fin s'il
rêve de nathalie rankin depuis toujours
d'avoir sa maison son chez-soi viennet
et dans quelques mois et pourra tout
aménagé à son goût j'ai mes deux
chambres de bain que je voulais on
convainc que je voulais la salle de
lavage ans ou qu'on voulait on se rêve
[Musique]
quittera le logement social qu élue au
conseil de bande depuis 23 ans qui
devenus trop petits avec les jumeaux way
manque d'espacé beaucoup à l'intérieur
les six ont presque trois ans puis en
dansant
l'hypothèque sera quatre fois plus élevé
que son loyer
mais l'investissement en vaut la peine
mais j'ai jamais sentie c'était chez
-100% j'avais 10 ou 20% ce problème de
la ville et devenir propriétaire quand
on est membre d'une première nation peut
s'avérer un véritable casse-tête vertu
de la loi sur les indiens les parcelles
de terrain dans une réserve sont
insaisissables
les banques ne prêtent pas d'argent
faute de garanties si on voit la caisse
populaire ou à la banque nationale
dessus de la ville d'amos eu aucun
recours pour venir chercher si les gens
font pour leur paiement
j'avais déjà que lorsqu'on stream
j'avais pas place martin bruneau qui est
en couple avec un autochtone de pikogan
depuis 19 ans et chargé de l'habitation
dans la communauté
elle a cherché de nouveaux modes de
financement et s'est tourné vers la cedh
ac la société dépend des autochtones du
canada qui a été créée justement pour
prêter à des gens comme la taille
ben moi je demande un projet d'une
maison de 200 mines ok ça fait une
maison de base est normal comme ce mec
un peu plus à mon style à mon goût
maintenant s'ils résident n'est plus
capable de payer son hypothèque
la cdec travail avec le conseil de bande
pour trouver un autre propriétaire
autochtone les gens sont peu au besoin
d'attendre après mois pour leur donner
deux maisons dans chapeau combien
d'années
car il est là le coeur du problème
acquis gaughan la liste d'attentes pour
obtenir un logement fournie par le
conseil de bande et de 10 à 15 ans on
est en crise du logement depuis toujours
puis cette année le gouvernement
m'accorde une construction une
construction s'agit d'une construction
plusieurs si demain matin on m'offrait
une baguette magique comme toi martine
quand même avant tout besoin de
construire il devra en consomme environ
61 mais avec des résidents comme
nathalie qui deviennent propriétaires et
qui se font construire leur propre
maison
ça permet de libérer des logements
sociaux pour ceux qui en ont le plus
besoin
on évite aussi que des familles quittent
la communauté pour d'avoir trouvé un
toit c'est la communauté
les grandes familles
je voulais pas sortir de taule
[Musique]
mais il ya aussi des défis liés à ce
genre d'initiatives maximum une
communauté moins riches située à environ
une heure de pikogan
on aimerait bien se tourner vers la
propriété privée deux tiers des
résidents vivre sur la sécurité sociale
mais pas plus quand on construit
[Musique]
financière qui vous ferez votre demande
probablement quelles institutions
financières voient refuser de vos
finances et lucien wabanonik reconnaît
qu'il y a une mentalité a changé et que
bien des gens qui sont habitués à payer
des loyers modestes ne seront pas prêts
à s'empêtrer d'une hypothèque beaucoup
plus coûteuse
même à pikogan une propriétaire se
comptent sur les doigts d'une main
jusqu'à maintenant c'est pas tout le
monde qui à leurs yeux d'avoir une
maison non plus si l'accès à la
propriété privée ne réglera pas tous les
problèmes
nathalie est contente d'avoir cette
option comprend les comme les mineurs et
personne de moins de 18 ans toute notre
vie non je trouve ça pas d'ailleurs de
penser ce gouvernement nous fournir des
logements et de ne pas avoir à attendre
l'argent d'ottawa pour réaliser son
règne mois puis maxime on est d'accord
pour cette maison là c'est l'héritage
des enfants ont donné le plus belle
ville du monde qu'il en donne est le
plus profitable